If Israel just allowed
the Palestinians to have a state of their own,
there would be peace in the Middle East, right?
That's what you hear from you and ambassadors,
European diplomats and most college professors.
But what if I told you that Israel has already offered
the Palestinians a state of their own
and not just once,
but on five separate occasions?
Don't believe me?
Let's review the record.
After the breakup of the Ottoman Empire
following World War 1,
Britain took control of most of the Middle East,
including the area that constitutes modern Israel.
Seventeen years later, in 1936,
the Arabs rebelled against the British
and against the Jewish neighbours.
The British formed a task force,
the Peel Commission,
to study the cause of the rebellion.
The commission concluded that
the reason for the violence was that two peoples,
Jews and Arabs,
wanted to govern the same land.
The answer, the Peel Commission concluded,
would be to create two independent states,
one for the Jews and one for the Arabs,
a two state solution.
The suggested split was heavily in favour of the Arabs.
The British offered them 80% of the disputed territory,
the Jews the remaining 20%.
Yet despite the tiny size of their proposed state,
the Jews voted to accept this offer,
but the Arabs rejected it
and resumed their violent rebellion.
Rejection No. 1.
Ten years later, in 1947,
the British asked the United Nations to find a
new solution to the continuing tensions
like the Peel Commission.
The UN decided that the best way to resolve
the conflict was to divide the land.
In November 1947,
the UN voted to create two states.
Again, the Jews accepted the offer and again
the Arabs rejected it.
Only this time
they did so by launching an all out war.
Rejection number two,
Jordan, Egypt, Iraq,
Lebanon and Syria join the conflict,
but they failed.
Israel won the war
and got on with the business of building a new nation.
Most of the land set aside by the UN for an Arab state,
the West Bank and East Jerusalem,
became occupied territory
occupied not by Israel,
but by Jordan.
Twenty years later,
in 1967, the Arabs,
LED this time by Egypt and joined by Syria and Jordan,
once again sought to destroy the Jewish state.
The 1967 conflict,
known as the Six Day War,
ended in a stunning victory for Israel.
Jerusalem in the West Bank,
as well as the area known as the Gaza Strip
fell into Israel's hands.
The government split over what to do with this
new territory.
Half wanted to return the West Bank to Jordan
and Gaza to Egypt in exchange for peace.
The other half wanted to give it to the region's Arabs,
who had begun referring to themselves as
the Palestinians
in the hope that they would
ultimately build their own state there.
Neither initiative got very far.
A few months later,
the Arab League met in Sudan
and issued its infamous three nos,
no peace With Israel,
no recognition of Israel,
no negotiations with Israel.
Again, a two state solution was dismissed by the Arabs,
making this rejection number three. In 2000,
Israeli Prime Minister Ehud Barack met at Camp David
with Palestinian Liberation Organization Chairman
Yasser Arafat
to conclude a new two state plan.
Barack offered Arafat a Palestinian state in
all of Gaza and 94% of the West Bank
with East Jerusalem as its capital.
But the Palestinian leader rejected the offer.
In the words of US President Bill Clinton,
Arafat was here 14 days and said no to everything.
Instead, the Palestinians launched
the bloody wave of suicide bombings that killed over
1,000 Israelis
and mained thousands more on buses,
in wedding halls
and in pizza parlors.
Rejection number four,
in 2008, Israel tried yet again.
Prime Minister Ehud
Omer went even further than Ehud Barak had,
expanding the peace offer to include additional land
to sweeten the deal.
Like his predecessor,
the new Palestinian leader,
Mahmoud Abbas
turned the deal down.
Rejection No. 5.
In between these last two Israeli offers,
Israel unilaterally left Gaza,
giving the Palestinians complete control there.
Instead of developing this territory
for the good of its citizens,
the Palestinians turned Gaza into a terrorist base
from which they have fired thousands of rockets
into Israel.
Each time Israel has agreed to a Palestinian state,
the Palestinians have rejected the offer,
often violently.
So if you're interested in peace in the Middle East,
maybe the answer is not to Pressure Israel to make
yet another offer of a state to the Palestinians?
Maybe the answer is to pressure the Palestinians
to finally accept the existence of a Jewish state.
I'm David Brogg,
executive director of the Maccabee Task Force
for Prager University.